I don't have the best news today, uh, for
the progressive movement in the context of
the 2020 democratic primary.
Now I know that there will be people who write
to me and say, David, these are the wrong
polls.
This is not trustworthy or whatever, but I
do it when progressives are up and I do it
when Progressive's are down because I'm reporting
to you what is going on out there.
And the latest polls, those that have been
released within the last couple of days showed
Joe Biden with one of the largest national
leads going all the way back to December of
2019.
And it gives me no pleasure to tell you this,
but this, I don't do what Trump does, right?
When the stock market's up, Trump tweets about
it.
When the stock market's down, he says nothing.
Or sometimes we'll say, I don't pay much attention
to the stock market.
Bernie surged recently and we covered it and
lately Joe Biden has recovered and I actually
don't fully understand what's going on.
In addition to that, after some very strong
showings from Bernie Sanders in Iowa, Joe
Biden is also, uh, in the lead there in a
recent poll.
Of course, Iowa is the first place where 2020
voting will happen very soon on third.
So let's go through it step by step.
First are the national polls.
The latest poll from survey USA says Biden
32 Sanders 21 Warren 14.
That is Biden plus 11 and this is the biggest
lead.
Biden has had an a national poll going back
to one released in late December where Biden
was plus 13.
Now also shockingly in this poll, Michael
Bloomberg is polling nine.
Not everybody believes that.
So understandably, there's some skepticism
here.
I don't know that I believe Bloomberg has
nine.
I don't know that Biden is really plus 11
but clearly as we continue to get closer and
closer to the votes starting, Joe Biden is
doing well here at the national level.
Now let's go and look at Iowa.
The big story two weeks ago in Iowa was that
Bernie Sanders took a lead in an important
Iowa poll.
The Des Moines register poll, the first state
to vote February 3rd it's a caucus format
and Bernie took a lead in the Des Moines register
poll 20 to 17 over Elizabeth Warren.
There is a 3.7 margin of error, but it was
important because Bernie clearly had the momentum
at the time.
The last couple of polls for Bernie and Iowa
are not as good.
The latest Monmouth poll has Joe Biden leading
in Iowa 24 to 18 over Bernie.
The latest focus on rural America poll Joe
Biden is plus six over Warren with Bernie
only at 14 in Iowa.
Again, you don't have to believe any particular
poll is exactly right, but if this is even
remotely accurate, Bernie might end up with
zero delegates in Iowa because remember, you
need 15% to get any delegates in primaries.
Now the question is, can we trust these polls
and what does this tell us about the dynamics
of the democratic primary?
Let's do, can we trust them first?
Generally speaking, you can trust these polls.
Okay, there's a margin of error.
We know that Bernie Sanders down 10 in Iowa
is outside of the margin of error.
Maybe he's really only down six or something
like that.
All we can do is wait and see and support
the person we want.
What I think is going on here is the more
important question and what's going on is
exactly as, as we predicted the entire Warren
Bernie dustup about Bernie said a woman can't
win to Elizabeth Warren back in 2018 it's
not about drastically moving support between
Bernie and Warren.
I think it's basically clear at this point
that Elizabeth Warren does not have a serious
path to securing the democratic nomination.
It's about muddling things up.
It's about making both Bernie and Warren seem
just kind of troublesome and buy time for
Joe Biden in first place to get to those first
votes, to let Joe Biden start accumulating
delegates and build establishment momentum
in that way.
I told you this before when the entire thing
started, the Bernie Warren's scandal or pseudo
scandal, it's not going to get Elizabeth Warren
into the lead.
It's going to reinforce the establishment.
It gives Biden more time in first place to
be seen in first place to reinforce being
in first place.
That is the way it works.
That's what we're seeing right now.
Now, if you disagree with my read of what's
going on, let me know.
But unfortunately this was predictable.
This is exactly what we anticipated.
Now in terms of other early States, New Hampshire
is second to vote.
Bernie is still leading there by one to five,
depending on the poll you look at.
That's a great for the progressive movement.
Um, at the same time, historically New Hampshire
is not super important in determining who
wins the democratic primary Nevada votes.
Third Biden is leading every recent poll there.
We only have two from 2020 Biden is plus one
and plus six that could also shift.
And then fourth to vote is South Carolina.
South Carolina has always been very easily
and Joe Biden's camp, uh, Joe Biden leading
by more than 20 points in the latest Fox news
poll.
Then you get to California and Bernie is ahead
in a number of recent polls in California.
Not every poll Burr Biden is actually ahead
by 10 points in one recent California poll.
I really have no idea what's going on in California.
I'm guessing that multiple candidates will
scoop up delegates there.
What's important to understand about the math
is unless a really long shot candidate gets
a bunch of delegates in California, if the
leaders, Biden, Bernie, and Warren each pickup
a similar number of delegates in California,
it doesn't really change the dynamics very
much because they're just kind of splitting
delegates and then it comes down to the States
where it's not close, but we'll have a more
detailed assessment of possible delegate counts
as the voting starts.
This is the reality we have, and I know some
people will write to me and say, David, but
you're not giving enough credence to this
one poll that has Bernie up one or something
like that.
These are the trends.
Okay?
I understand that not every poll, uh, is going
to confirm what we might believe is going
on.
But if we zoom out and look at the trends,
Biden is continuing to just remain there in
that front runner position in a lot of key
States and now nationally, something is going
to have to happen and relatively quickly,
uh, for a progressive to have a shot.
Warren increasingly seems mathematically,
uh, almost out at this point when it comes
to a path to the nomination.
Bernie still in it, but the numbers are going
to have to shift in his favor if that's going
to become a thing.
Let me know
what
you
think
about my read on
all of this.